if we just give them enough money they  will fix climate change how much money  exactly do they need and how much have  we given already well Joe summed it up  quite nicely look what I ran on I said  we're going to deal with energy right  and and the energy problem we're going  to deal with the whole notion of global  warming we passed 368 billion dollars  worth of help which as the same Bankers  talk about that's going to bring up  billions a trillions 700 million dollar  billion dollars off the sidelines no you  couldn't make it any clearer out of the  368 billion that we put into climate  change and I'm sure that'll stop you  know if you just throw cash at Mother  Nature Chili's up what's the return on  it guys according to Joe Biden we're  going to get a billion trillion times 50  million climate change  wait wait like I don't think that would  work on a calculator right there's not  enough numbers on there punch them just  crunch them please  the man is an idiot come on